all right here with the latest Insider
Advantage chairman Matt Towery Chief
pollster at the Trafalgar group Robert
kahaly let me praise both of you both of
you showed up as two of the top
pollsters in America I noticed some real
clear politics uh congratulations to
both of you
thank you well thank you we a lot of
people were involved in that uh over the
years so I'm certainly yeah better be
right then on Tuesday
because if not you're going to be they
might take it back polling is a hard
thing to do
um let's look at the Senate and Robert
kahali we're going to go through real
quick both of you we'll start with
Georgia uh Robert who's going to win
Georgia in the Senate
Herschel
Matt
I think it could be a runoff but I think
Walker is the favorite either way
okay let's go to North Carolina Ted Budd
Matt
bud
what do you think Robert
not even close let's go to bullduck in
New Hampshire Robert
barely but Boulder
what do you think Matt
ah toss-up right now I don't have an
answer but momentum is with bouldered
okay let's look at Pennsylvania and Oz
Matt Towery who's going to win that race
well based on the polling I should win
but Pennsylvania is a weird place in
terms of how they Count Their ballots
and the like so I'm going to have to
hold my breath and say it's a toss-up
wow thoughts uh Robert what do you think
I think Ozzie gets the most votes
oh boy that that is a loaded that's what
Robert says every time that's a loaded
term you just threw out there
um in the
end do you think Oz wins this
Robert
I think whether he wins is like Matt
said it's a toss-up all right let's look
at uh JD Vance in Ohio thoughts Robert
Vance not close Okay Matt
yeah same I agree Ron Johnson in
Wisconsin Matt
yeah he's got it what do you think
Robert
I think he wins but he because he's an
incumbent he might he might be a little
under what the polling says okay let's
look at lack salt in in Nevada Matt
that one I believe is going to be one of
the two seats that will probably cause
Republicans to secure the Senate I think
he wins okay Robert you agree
definitely
and what do you think about new uh
Arizona Blake Masters Robert
I feel like masters with the uh
libertarian getting out I think he's got
a real Advantage now and he'll close the
gap so I think I think he wins it but
buy a hair what do you think Matt
I basically agree I think Kerry lake is
running so strong that that's going to
help push him over the edge let's look
at three gubernatorial races New York
Michigan with Tudor Dixon Lee Zelda to
New York and Carrie Lake in Arizona who
wins those three races Matt Towery
Well Carrie lake is going to win in
Arizona based on the polling we've been
doing for the fox affiliate there
Michigan's going to be an absolute tight
tight race to the end and I'm not even
going to talk about New York because
Robert is the man who discovered there
was a close race there in the first
place so I'll toss that to him all right
you're punting on that one I love how
you guys punt back and forth uh Robert
what's your take on the three
well first of all I think Kerry Kerry
lake is a is the new Superstar of the
Republican party and uh I think she's
going to win and she's going to impress
people by how well she wins I think
Michigan is a toss-up and it's more
about what the turnout for opposition to
the ballot initiative three does that is
going to drive that race more than any
other factor and um
New York I think it is very very close
but it really could go either way and um
it's going to be about crime but it's
just a matter of it's going to be a
toss-up all right uh thank you both and
congratulations also to both of you uh
the highest rankings on real clear
politics in terms of posters in America
we appreciate you being with us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else